I'm Ben Dominic I'm Ainsley Earhart I'm
Trey Gowdy and this is the Fox News
Rundown
Wednesday September 28 2022 only Lisa
Brady what could be a historic storm
sets off in nearly Statewide scramble
Floridians are accustomed to knowing the
sort of part of the Year where
hurricanes are prevalent and and we have
our sort of checklist of things that we
that we normally say and do and that
doesn't vary very much we speak with
Miami mayor Francis Suarez I'm Dave
Anthony there has been a record surge
this year of migrants coming to the U.S
illegally and those numbers don't even
count the ones across the border but
weren't caught they're the ones that
break into the ranches they're the ones
that are stealing the cars they're the
ones that are causing a lot of criminal
activity in the most remote parts of the
Del Rio sector and I'm Carol Markowitz
I've got the final word on the Fox News
Rundown
[Music]
they're used to hurricanes in Florida
but not every storm is as big and strong
as hurricane Ian the impacts are going
to be far far broader than just where
the eye of the storm happens to make
landfall Governor Ron DeSantis says some
areas will have catastrophic flooding
you know they talk about hiding from
wind but running from water and so when
you have massive storm surge it could
hit make 10 12 feet that is something
that is life-threatening by Tuesday
evening more than 2 million people had
been ordered to evacuate and a hurricane
warning was extended from the Gulf Coast
into Orlando the forecast especially
concerning for the Tampa Bay area which
hasn't been hit by a major hurricane in
more than a century the Tampa and
Orlando airports shutting down along
with theme parks including Disney some
of the schools closed by the storm being
used as shelters your safety is more
important than anything and I know our
hearts are with everyone who will feel
the effects of this storm and we'll be
with you every step of the way we're not
going away President Biden urging people
to heed local orders and it appeared
many were with shelters and hotels
filling up and long lines for supplies
like sandbags bills tiresome tiresome
but hey you got to do what you got to do
NASA even rolling its new moon rocket
from the launch pad back into the hangar
at Kennedy Space Center which will
further delay the first test flight well
we prepare for all hurricanes the same
way right we take it seriously we assume
the worst Miami mayor Francis Suarez and
we prepare for the worst we
unfortunately have a lot of experience
dealing with hurricanes but we are
assuming that the impacts and the
effects for that will be uh worse than
what we expect and we're hopeful that
that doesn't turn off to be the case
are you satisfied with the state's
response what they have been doing
um to help the entire State prepare
yeah I think the state again just like
the city we have a lot of experience uh
with these events and so there's a lot
of cross-coordination going on our Urban
search and rescue team has already been
activated we also have a Strike Team
from Miami
um that will be ready to help Tampa the
Tampa Bay Area
um and I haven't been in contact with
the mayor of of Tampa as well and so
there's been a lot of coordination with
the state and throughout the state there
hasn't been as much time to prepare for
this one as with some storms you know
how much more difficult is it to be
ready obviously you can have those teams
in place but in terms of you know
opening shelters and and that sort of
things and giving residents time to get
their own properties ready they're just
you know the lead time is isn't as long
for this one
I can tell you that on Friday people
were surprised they were shocked to know
that there was a storm brewing
um you know normally we would have lead
time but like I said you know Floridians
are accustomed to uh knowing the sort of
uh part of the Year where hurricanes are
prevalent and and we have our sort of
checklist of things that we that we
normally say and do and that doesn't
vary very much what's the main concern
for Miami this time especially being a
coastal city
the big concern for us there's always a
flooding and we've become significantly
more wind resilient in turkey and Andrew
in 1992 when we had sustained winds over
200 miles an hour we changed our entire
building codes so pretty much every
building has either storm shutters or
storm windows impact windows so the big
issue and the big concern always is
flooding and storm surge in that area
which as we saw during Irma which had a
you know four to six foot storm surge uh
can can really damage things and and uh
incapacitate uh important areas of the
city
I know you've said that climate change
is affecting your city already and
that's something the Republican party is
often accused of denying or at least
downplaying what does Miami need to do
or what are you already doing to deal
with the impacts of climate change
I can tell you that a republican
governor and a republican legislature
both Senate and House have been unified
with a Republican mayor in spending
money prophylactically on the front end
to support our resiliency efforts we
have a program called Miami forever
which is basically spending money to
make sure that Miami on the
infrastructure side is here forever and
when you look at the infrastructure bill
when you look at you know which which
was also supported by uh Republicans
even the former president wanted
actually a larger infrastructure bill
that was ultimately passed
um you know there's a tremendous amount
of emphasis by both state federal and
local governments to spend money
preemptively because we know that a
dollar spent uh preempting uh damage
saves about seven to eight dollars on
the back end in post damage so it's it's
the most efficient way to spend money
we've we've uh our voters approved the
tax which we don't like to tax ourselves
but our voters approve the tax that
spends 200 million hours and resiliency
the state has given us an additional 50
and of course we'll try to get some from
the federal government as well is this
an area where nationally you wish maybe
that the Republican party was more
proactive about it more upfront about it
acknowledging you know the risks of
climate change
yeah I think we need to change the
conversation a bit I think with a lot of
these things that become very partisan
unfortunately uh the conversation isn't
a healthy one and I think one of the
things we say in Miami is our
environment is our economy it's not one
or the other and when you look at the
Everglades which is a you know produces
billions of dollars of revenue for our
region and also all of our drinking
water when you look at our coral reef
system and ecotourism I think we're
eighth in the nation in green jobs uh so
you know it's part of our economy um so
I think if we look at it as an economic
engine as an economic driver of
high-paying jobs then it takes on a
different context and then when you also
think about it as flooding when you see
events like hurricanes uh where you were
flooding and storm surge is is
undeniable right then it you know you
don't have to get into so much the
causality as you do making sure that
we're resilient as a country uh to
whatever Mother Nature can throw our way
are you concerned that the southern
coast or Florida in general you know
could be hit it more often more
frequently with these kinds of intense
storms or do you hear that concern
coming from residents
yeah I think for us it's not so much
about the amount or intensity of events
it's really more about our ability to
deal with them right uh after Hurricane
Andrew basically upgrading our codes
having storm shutters and impact Windows
essentially made us sort of impenetrable
with respect to wind we need to get to
that same level with respect to water
and if we do then a hurricane will be
nothing more than uh you know an
unfortunate event where you have to
cancel school and cancel certain things
but it doesn't create the level of
Devastation that it's created up until
now tough times of course for many
Americans in general with inflation
running so High
um how's the city doing in general
well we're doing phenomenally well
um and we're doing it because we're
following a model that works and that's
we keep taxes low we just reduced our
tax rate to the lowest in our history
and that has spurred growth we had 12
growth that's the second most uh since
we've been keeping that statistic uh
We've leaned into Innovation creating
high-paying jobs we're number one in the
nation in wage growth and we're keeping
people safe with the resources that we
have uh we have more police officers
than we've ever had in our history and
our homicide rate per capita is on the
precipice and I knock on wood when I say
that of being the lowest that it's been
in our history so we're making the right
strategic Investments we're taking less
money out of people's pockets and we're
just attracting uh everyone because
we're the most attractive City in the
you know arguably in the world I know
right now you're also President of the
U.S Conference of Mayors are more cities
trying some of your policies now or do
they ask you about them there's
definitely a buzz about them and I
always say about our model it's easy to
articulate sometimes hard to follow it
requires sometimes standing up to you
know sort of the liberal narrative in
the liberal media narrative that
government is a solver of all problems
and we know that that level of
government Intervention which many
people call Socialism or communism has
only created equal misery for people and
so it it you know government has a
limited competency should be limited in
size and the rest should be left to
people to be able to spend and save and
and you know invest as they see fit I
know your father was the first
cuban-born mayor of Miami now you're the
first miami-born mayor of the city he
ran as a Democrat though right why the
Republican party for you
well actually I think he was an
independent but he was he's at one point
been a Republican and independent and a
Democrat which I think it highlights his
sort of independent thinking you know
I've been a republican since I was 18
years old since I was registered to vote
and I just believe in in the values of
the Republican party and having limited
government uh you know and focusing on
uh you know this country which is the
greatest country on the planet uh and so
that to me is how I've built our city
right creating more prosperity and
leaning into the fact that you know our
Democratic experiment it is what has
created the most Liberty and freedom for
the most number of people in the history
of humanity there certainly has been a
buzz about your potential future
aspirations
um you haven't ruled out a run for
president one day even talked about a
new generation of leaders are you
concerned at all about the Republican
Party heading into the midterms you know
I think if we focus on a platform uh
that's similar to what Miami has done if
we focus on reducing taxes and balancing
our budget if we focus on increasing a
funding for police instead of this
nonsense of defunding police and we
focus on making our country the most
competitive for a generation by
understanding the threats of China in
their Investments on artificial
intelligence and Quantum Computing and
our supply chain issues then I think
that is a recipe for success for the
Republican party we should focus on the
things that we know are going to create
prosperity for people and I think that's
a compelling message the former
president appears to still hold a lot of
sway in the party regardless of legal
troubles or the January 6th committee
getting ready to wrap up its
investigation is there too much focus on
Trump or no Trump and you know if the
answer is moving on how does that happen
without destroying the party in the
process
well I think that's up to the American
people and I think that's up to the you
know Republicans in terms of a primary
right the questions they have to ask
themselves are do we want you know
another baby boomer or do we want a Next
Generation candidate you know do we want
uh someone who has uh you know who's
tapping into anger which is a perfectly
understandable emotion at this point or
do we want someone that's going to
create a positive and inspiring vision
for the future of this country you know
do we want someone that can communicate
with and connect with the largest
minority demographic that happens to be
training Republican which are Hispanics
you know and do we want someone that uh
you know understands how to create
high-paying jobs and has done it before
because they understand how disruptive
the world is and how things are changing
and we have to create the kind of
opportunities that are going to create
prosperity for a generation that's the
question that this country has to ask
itself and the party has to ask itself
and I think the answer to that question
is going to determine whether or not the
former president is the nominee of the
party
what does it take for you mayor Francis
Juarez to take the plunge and seek a
higher office what would be the Tipping
Point for you
you know I think the Tipping Point for
me would be you know first of all
obviously you know getting to a place
where there is a significant amount of
excitement over a candidate that could
you know answer those four questions in
a way that creates uh excitement for
this country and I think you know we're
at a place with so much division uh so
much uh destructive politics that you
know the question that is whether or not
the country's going to be ready for a
Next Generation positive aspirational
leader right that's really what I'm what
I'm looking at what I'm focused on and
if that the answer to that question is
yes and you know obviously I have to
seriously consider it because I just
don't see anyone else providing that
kind of leadership in that message Miami
mayor Francis Juarez thank you very very
much for your time thank you
foreign
[Music]
this is Carol Markowitz with your Fox
News commentary coming up
Congress is on deadline to approve new
funding by the end of this week or the
government could shut down Republicans
say they'll vote no without money for
border security amid a record surge of
migrants coming here illegally
congresswoman Beth Van Dyne from Texas
tells Fox yeah I think it's it's obvious
our current system cannot handle the
influx and I have not seen a plan at all
from this President and what we've seen
over the last year and a half is a
complete denial that there's a problem
now President Biden says a lot of the
migrants are now coming from Cuba
Nicaragua and Venezuela and the ability
to send them back to those States is not
rational you could send them back and
have them while we're working with
Mexico and other countries to see if we
can stop the flow but that's the
difference Republican Texas governor
Greg Abbott blames Biden policies and
his controversially bust thousands of
migrants to Chicago New York and
Washington D.C we have small communities
of about 25
000 people who have thousands of illegal
immigrants dumped into their community
and so they were begging for Relief and
that's exactly why we began this busing
operation so far this fiscal year more
than 2 million migrants have been
stopped at the border and if you add the
previous year that totals about 3
million people that have entered through
illegal courts of Entry which is
basically just crossing the river or the
land Crossings Bruno lozanos the former
mayor of Del Rio Texas and a Democrat
that's larger than many metropolitan
areas in the United States and I think
that should really send the alarms to
the administration that this is a crisis
and it still baffles me that vice
president Harris still still does not
call this a crisis for what it is all
right you bring her up because when
President Biden took office and we
started seeing a surge in the first few
months he put her as like the borders
are and she was supposed to get to the
root causes of why people are coming
here
but she hasn't been to Del Rio did you
ever have a conversation with anyone in
the Biden Administration
Homeland Security anybody about the
situation you've been facing in your
community
I did speak directly to the
administration as secretary mayorkas
which is Department of Homeland Security
I had been trying to reach the
administration prior to that I'm not
sure if you recall but back in February
of 2021 we had a winter storm that hit
Texas and during that week's time Border
Patrol was trying to release I believe
at the time six migrants into Del Rio's
vicinity and let me remind you that we
did not we had no power we had no
electricity no food we didn't have
running water and I'm somehow supposed
to manage the release of six migrants
and it's laughable now looking back
because it's just six people but that's
just how disconnected the administration
was with an ongoing crisis an
environmental crisis in Del Rio and
that's when it began doing YouTube
videos to try to get them to come down
and visit the city and that went without
any game it didn't move very far but I
did speak to secretary America's only
after the fact that there was the Border
crisis of the Haitians going underneath
the bridge or being placed underneath
the bridge back in September of 2021 so
a year ago that was a huge story last
year thousands and thousands of Haitians
in your community under a bridge at the
border
and ultimately they finally were cleared
out but most of them just were allowed
into the United States correct they were
just waiting to get detained by their
border patrol and after the border
patrol takes him into custody into
detention that's when they get split
into different sectors along the border
or different processing centers and yes
once they're given their documents
they're able to continue their journey
to wherever their destination was the
Haitian population the majority of them
were headed to Brooklyn which is in the
city of New York
you're on the border you deal with a lot
of people crossing that you say don't
want to be there but ultimately you have
to house them how does it work they're
they're detained by border patrol and
then just dropped off in Del Rio and and
what happens to them at that point when
that happens you know the bigger cities
have infrastructure available and they
have larger non-profit organizations
that can kind of jump in and mitigate
this process Del Rio and Eagle Pass are
smaller border communities and we don't
have those kind of resources available
the fact of the matter is is that we're
still seeing 1500 migrants a day across
the Del Rio sector 1500 migrants are
entering through illegal points of entry
and the border patrol is continuously
backed up in their own border patrol
centers so once they drop them off into
the city of Del Rio
it's kind of um under there's no written
rule but they'll drop off about 300 to
500 different people in one day and our
non-profit will will do their very best
to get them access to a computer or cell
phone or what have you so they can
contact their sponsor purchase their
tickets and then just continue their
Journey but oftentimes what happens is
that if they don't get a ticket they'll
stay at a local convenience store
waiting for their bus every single day
it just gets larger and larger and
larger the backlog of people that are
just trying to get through our
communities how big is Del Rio you're
talking about you know 1500 migrants a
day in a city of of how many people
36 000 people the county is 50 000
people so we're not super large we're
not a big city so you have a lot to
process there and that's just those who
are apprehended there's also the
godaways and there's a lot of those too
who who aren't stopped so when I got
some information some stats the Del Rio
sector has already exceeded 450 000
persons detained this fiscal year and
that I believe set the record to where
we're the largest sector now receiving
these migrants right the God always has
160 000 people is what my understanding
was and that's a lot of people that go
undetected they get away and those are
the people that are very concerning
because you know they don't know who
they are they could be terrorist
organizations they could be you know
people transporting drugs and different
paraphernalia into their country they're
the ones that break into the ranches
they're the ones that are stealing the
cars they're the ones that are causing a
lot of criminal activity in the most
remote parts of of the Del Rio sector
back to Governor Abbott bussing all
those migrants North it's the rose type
of politics it's hateful politics New
York city mayor Eric Adams a Democrat
says Abbott's using him as political
pawns by taking away the respect and
dignity of people who are in need what
the Texas governor is doing is just so
anti-American Florida Governor Ron
DeSantis also called inhumane and
immoral for sending two flights of
migrants to Martha's Vineyard in
Massachusetts oh by the way they already
bust them out they're gone they said
they said we want everyone no one's
illegal and they're gone within 48 hours
and the Republicans as more journalists
rushed to Martha's Vineyard than have
ever gone down to the southern border to
look what's going on why don't you go
down there and look what some of those
communities have to deal with every day
so what does former mayor Lozano and Del
Rio think of those buses and flights if
anybody's being lured into or being kind
of suckered into taking these this
transfer system I'm not supporting that
all but at the same token I do look at
it like it's a safe way to get to their
destination you know a lot of the
migrants are actually going to these
communities where they're being sent to
by the governors you know a couple years
ago when I was in the height of my
mayorship I had conversations where we
would talk about immigration policy is
is breaking it's falling apart and two
years later it's not breaking it's not
falling apart it is broken it has fallen
apart you know I had in my experience
during the crisis last year I had more
if not 99 of the visitors were
Republican elected officials you know
from different districts different
congressional districts in the state I
had out-of-state Congressional visitors
and I would also invite the Democratic
elected officials to come into the to
the border and none of them came you
know I did have a delegation from the
borough of Brooklyn where a lot of the
Haitians were going I had a council
member come down with her delegation but
it seems like a lot of them were
misinformed and just trying to point
fingers to say this is the mayor's fault
or this is the city's fault this is the
crisis when that's just the tip of the
iceberg if you could fix it so that if
somebody said all right mayor Lozano
your job now is to find a solution what
would it be I would begin the
immigration process Asylum seeking
process and Home Country I think that
would help alleviate a lot of the
unlawful Crossings to begin with and
begin kind of a cue you know and then
expand the facilities at the border the
legal ports of Entry all of our land
ports all of our seaports and all of our
airports can facilitate the inbound flux
of persons seeking Asylum and then that
way there's no waiting period that way
they don't have to come back to a court
date they don't have to come back and
and try to figure out their case it's
already kind of a predetermined
situation through the online process I
think that would be a great start I grew
up in Del Rio and you know we had
illegal crossers and a lot of them were
just Mexican men at the time this was
back in the late 90s early 2000s and
then as the years changed now it's
family units and their families from
Venezuela from Haiti from from all over
the world these individuals and these
families are permanently moving to the
United States and they're Crossing an
unprecedented numbers illegally yeah and
they're allowed and they're allowed to
go into the interior of the country is
that the problem they know they're going
to just be let in I'm a firm believer
I'm a veteran of the United States
military and I protect the Constitution
and I think that we have Law and Order
for a reason and to just let anybody in
without having vetted having processed
is is lack of due diligence on
Department of Homeland Security
Securities part we need to make sure
that we're not allowing rapists or or
terrorists or people that are trying to
do harm with the context that they're
just trying to seek Asylum either yeah
you know for president Trump I mean
Donald Trump took a beating for using
those terms for people coming across
when he started running for president he
did he took a beating for that I know I
I did and I
I you know even myself I get you know
it's it's I I still say the word illegal
it's a legal term to say the word
illegal there's nothing inherently wrong
with saying they people have entered
this country illegally I thought last
year was was unprecedented now we have a
second year in a row unprecedented if
nothing changes in your opinion will
this just go on and unending it's going
to continue to get worse as more
economies and countries across the globe
continue to collapse for whatever reason
whether it's social whether it's you
know a coup or environmental people are
fleeing their home countries and trying
to find better opportunities and we all
agree everybody should be wanting a
better life but do not enter illegally
it's it's how hard is that to complete
to comprehend you know and and and I
think what hasn't been mentioned is the
fact of the matter that the cartels in
Mexico are making millions if not
billions of dollars for each person that
crosses it's and that's another fact
that continues to get ignored you know
you're you're inherently allowing
illegal groups in Mexico to continue to
thrive through this broken failing
system
Bruno Lozano former mayor of Del Rio
Texas a Democrat thank you so much for
joining us I appreciate it
[Music]
and in other news I'm Gianna jalosi his
catchphrase is you can't see me but
we're all seeing this good deed WWE
Superstar John Cena has set a new
Guinness World Record and it doesn't
have anything to do with his moves in
the ring or his championship belts he's
granted the most wishes through the
Make-A-Wish Foundation after granting
650 wishes that number was verified by
Guinness on July 19th Cena granted his
first wish through the foundation in
2002 three years after his professional
wrestling debut ten years later he
granted make-a-wish's 1000th wish the
Make-A-Wish Foundation helps fulfill the
wishes of kids who have been diagnosed
with a life-threatening illness children
between two and a half years old and 18
years old can choose to meet a celebrity
go to an event or give a gift to
somebody else those that choose John
Cena can take pictures hang out see the
championship belts up close and
sometimes even get in the ring with the
wrestling Legend make a wish said the
16-time WWE World Champion is the most
requested celebrity and that no one
except for Cena has ever granted more
than 200 wishes in the foundation's
history the 45 year old has also
spearheaded the WWE's be a star
anti-bullying Initiative for the Fox
News rundown I'm Gianna jelosi
personal
America's weather team in the palm of
your hands get Fox weather updates
throughout your busy day every day
subscribe and listen now at
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you get
your podcasts Raiden review the Fox News
rundown on Apple podcasts or wherever
you listen it's time for your Fox News
commentary Carol martinowicz what's on
your mind Taylor Ellingson was killed
last week in North Dakota after another
man Shannon Brandt 41 hit him with his
SUV Ellingson was 18 years old Brant was
convinced the teenager was affiliated
with a republican extremist group no
evidence exists for this claim footage
of Brandt's bail hearing shows him
seeming confused that he may suffer for
his actions it comes right from the top
the president of the United States
supported by a fangirl media spouts
irresponsible rhetoric that led to
ellingson's death earlier this month
President Joe Biden gave a fiery speech
about the threats our country faced
cases from voters who dare to disagree
with him
red background clenched fists the
president shouted into the microphone
that America is at an inflection point
because manga Republicans do not respect
the Constitution
Donald Trump and the Mago Republicans
represent an extremism that threatens
the very foundations of our Republic he
said the message Biden sent to unstable
people like Brant is that it's
reasonable to get rid of those who
threaten our nation how can anyone not
defend his country over the weekend
Hillary Clinton added fuel to this fire
by liking Trump supporters to Nazis
I remember as a young student you know
trying to figure out how people get
basically drawn in by Hitler how did
that happen I'd watch newsreels and I'd
see this guy standing there ranting and
raving and people shouting and raising
their arms I thought what happened to
these people Clinton said at the Texas
Tribune Festival in Austin you saw the
rally in Ohio the other night Trump is
there ranting and raving for more than
an hour and you have these rows of young
men with their arms raised I thought
what is going on she said we all know if
Trump had declared some democratic
voters an existential threat to the
country and a death resulted it would
get wall to wall media coverage but
ellingson's killing has barely been a
blip and few in the media are pointing
out that a former major presidential
candidate comparing people with their
arms up to some of History's Greatest
monsters is using inflamed language that
could lead to more violence of the type
we saw in North Dakota Republicans hear
Democrats message and the complacent
media silence and since they don't
matter to these Elites the violence
Democrats condone with a wink never gets
blamed on them their media friends love
the idea of treating the wrong voting
right this way
our country is damaged when half the
population is treated as a fringe group
pushed out of public life and faced with
violence for their opinions it's way
past the time for the media to tell
Biden Clinton and the rest that their
language is simply unacceptable it's
destroying our country far more than
some shadowy right-wing group ever could
they don't even have to pretend to care
about Republicans to send that message
they just have to know that it won't end
with only the left running over their
political foes this is Carol Marco it's
columnist at the New York Post and Fox
News
[Music]
subscribing to this podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
new from the Fox News podcasts Network
my name is Kennedy and welcome to my
podcast which will I humbly say
single-handedly save the world you're
welcome it's Kennedy Saves the World
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
love Fox News click the Subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the Fox News rundown
playlist for the latest episodes